[Music]
robot arms in space
[Music]
fungus that breaks down pollution
knowing the root of happiness
much of what we know today was once
thought to be impossible
unreachable feats that stretch the
imagination
but what transforms the impossible
to possible
knowledge it's 1.4 billion years of data
research
pushing the frontiers of science to make
ideas for the greater good of the world
real
at cfar that's what we're able to do
building inclusive nations is necessary
to convene the brightest minds from
around the world from every discipline
the neural oscillations in your brain to
challenge the status quo that will take
ai to the next step to pursue high-risk
ideas they are a new type of machine to
allow borderless research to bring to
life what many thought could not exist
and you can actually see the chemistry
new ideas that enhance the everyday
new ideas that enhance our understanding
of the world we are now at the dawn of a
new age
new ideas that improve humanity it has
gotten quite a bit of attention
so
understand why we champion
world-renowned researchers and nurture
the next generation of talent to defy
the impossible that suggests to us that
there are legacies of trauma that start
off in one generation and then
perpetuate across generations
because global excellence via the 20
nobel prizes in 40 years or the 1700
major awards it all comes from
understanding that anything can be
[Music]
together
we build a possible future
cfar
believe the impossible
learn more at
cfar.ca
40.